[Music]
in sexy time news submitted by Joe's
left toe COO showed off a customized sex
toy that was a gift from a husband to
his wife goes up on sale at an auction
Oh are they famous why that's sad that's
years customized does that mean like
it's the shape of his dick many times
has it been used and if it's an auction
does it have [__] rhinestones on it
because it better
is it like a white-trash auction it's
like it's like $8 $8 we have a penis in
the state oh maybe that's right
yeah that's weird why would you want to
use sex toy of some other guys some
actual guy's penis yeah so the reason
why this sex toy is up for sale at
auction because it's a victorian-era sex
toy whoa what's the mice not cuz of
myzel or it was customized for the wife
so this was taking place or they're
assuming that the husband created this
for his wife around 1840 so cool cuz
back then when you leave town she leave
town for a long six months yeah like Abe
Lincoln used to go around the [__]
battlefields when he was you know
president and like you know Mary you got
Mary Todd at home yep you better believe
Mary Todd had a freaking deal
yep I'm not taking the bet again man -
so oh yes yes she probably had to have a
bigger deal to make up I heard George
Washington had one for his wife Oh
Martha I mean out of would hope should
he get splinters check that's the rumor
yeah sure what else have been polished
really well I think it was yeah they're
saying that this sex toy comes from a
well known Anglo Irish family which I
don't know which family but they traced
back the [__] lineage of this [__]
bill there's all kinds of DNA on there
not everything the good ol small test if
there's not I gonna pay less at auction
so they're saying that the original
owner was in India in the 1840s where he
shot himself an elephant and he brought
back the tusks home so he ended up
having this customized bill out of ivory
oh it's not that big like to scale like
because what it looks like it looks like
this big oh yeah - and I didn't really
they didn't mention it's just a pinkie
size well cuz you get the know there's
nothing a skillet there isn't well you
can imagine the size of the elephants
tusks and like the even the end of an
elephant's tusk is still like pretty big
yeah he's at least with wise I'm the
only thing we have to scale this maybe
that keyhole so it's way you don't know
how big the kids regardless that's a key
dude yeah you can see it it's
microscopic so you guys look closely
there's a heart and great or carved in
here it's also if you get deep enough
you can feel that a little bit of that
little uh little bit of longer in there
yeah and they're saying that there was
also like some something carved inside
of it for her to put a lock of his hair
which I thought was really weird looks
like - it's a more personal that way
like the skin fold that's so sweet
it's a guy that cares about him cut
about her coming that is really like for
the time when women were property like
for him to care about her equal its
sexual pleasure what they're saying
though is that in that era they didn't
really see this as like a sexual thing
they saw it as a a relief for hysteria
because they thought these women were
hysterical give this lady a dick she's
crazy
it either worked now though yeah yeah
are you pretty crazy when I haven't had
a dick in a while Daniel dick any day
medics of that period they believe that
like anxious and stressed that woman
could be cured if doctored it a little
bit a little bit what massage room
doctors massage patients to take them to
a state of hysterical paroxysm which
today we know it as orgasm but yeah
there's a soldiers would perform some
[__] to sex toys were invented because
doctors got too tired or they deliver
little like giving their hands so that's
how vibrators were not your [__]
[__] I love this [__] doctors just
wanted to diddle [__] I get it I
don't want to do [__] my hands are
tired I'm gonna use my dick I'm gonna
use my advantage position as a physician
and she's my patient and I'm gonna do
what I want I still think it's sweet
that he's there's a contraption part
that holds the lock of his hair and
there's a hard personalized yeah it's
still sweet he's creepy is funny dude
but that's also like man my girlfriend's
crazier my wife is crazy she needs this
can you make me a dick toy with your
hair in it you actually want that cuz I
can do that pretty easily yeah I do it
to be turned on hard and then do it
mm-hmm that's a lot dude together man
but I get good I get to know when you I
get to know when you can't use one at
home oh why cuz [__] that [__] you all
jealous of it like hey yeah get my dick
out of you know sometimes I would just
look at it and be like it's like cloned
the only part of you that I want I would
start to resent it I'm done with you
after a while I would have a whole
conversation with it like Willem Dafoe
did and Spiderman he's talking himself
in the mirror
[__] I do this [__] yo man what the [__]
dude really you you tonight or me
yeah but the auction mirror was saying
that 99% of the country in that time
they were just trying to get by so there
were perhaps 400 or 500 families in the
entire country who had these kinds of
means to even travel and bring back an
elephant us again Ireland or something
like a bet where yeah and so they hunted
this elephant they're wearing those
high-waisted short things right with the
[__] pith helmet right and the road
big rhino gun or whatever they have
right and then they shoot the [__] it
goes down and they're like yes we could
now make the dildo like that's that's a
huge elephant for that right that's what
happened for that that's still poach
elephants for ivory it still happens but
not for dildo make no but for no but
we're actually like penis grub penis
enhancement pills because they think
that Rhino rhino tusks and our elephant
tusks like it makes your dick bigger
really yeah yeah it does to my thumbs
yeah no I don't know just have a rival
form doesn't why they shootin wild rhino
they should make wine off of farms and
they can just I don't know I'm just
trying to think of like you can't take
out all those animals and then expect
them to come back you got to make a
farmer for something well but then
you're like wasting a whole like no one
eats rhino meat here's the thing well
what you got to do is take every
endangered species okay and this is like
bald eagles or whatever what's the most
endangered species right now let's say
it's Paul D yeah okay you tell guys
everyone you release the news articles
is like bald eagle feathers can make
dick's bigger than dates god no no no no
now dudes are like oh [__] they're
endangered we gotta [__] breathe
these [__] now dudes are [__] hobby
breathing yeah Paul yeah what happens
I guarantee it dude you're creating a
demand and people
just gonna hunt the Eagles yeah I think
they're gonna plug all the exactly
because why wouldn't they breathe the
Rhinos an elf oh dude I know it's like
science releases a medical journal and
says hey if you kill a rhino there's
something like you're using what they
release your dick shrinks yeah that's
right there's a kind of collection that
I thought you were gonna go that's
pretty I thought you were gonna say the
feathers make your dick small so you
can't get don't touch it yeah are you
shootin blanks dude yeah you don't want
to see it it emits a toxin Jackson
whisper it's your dick yeah you gonna
make it into a vagina it goes in your
body you [__] yourself and it's with
it's a scientific term they call mega
shrinkage yeah and it's like there's
pictures attached to them after you
shoot rhinos you shoot elephants tigers
you hurt an animal yep your dog good hot
shot you put a cat in the microwave yep
you throw the dogs into the Grand Canyon
that's what's gonna close up that's
what's actually down for quite a while
oh my god I want to be a kid have you
guys watch the animal cop show it's kind
of like cops but first I want to go on
that show you want to go guys [__] yeah
it's called animal oh yeah I've seen
that show he's always seen it like where
they were using horses Oh like oh it's
mostly like neglected malnourished it's
a straight like cockfighting thing or a
dogfighting thing or whatever I want to
go in there and then I'm also punishing
the people and then giving them a big
fat lecture and then for the after they
get a lecture then I'm gonna make them
human fight yeah and then pay for it and
then I'm gonna be better than a UFC and
then you're gonna have all the animals
lined up in a circle around them well I
don't even fight in the middle yep Baker
watch that's good a dad like that make
sure of the day because that's what they
do the ham uh-huh no rules oh my god
it's gonna be like Rome and the
Colosseum all over again but fair it's
like UFC but like you know not [__]
like it's humane it's fine because we're
doing it to people that already [__]
up in life if you [__] up and you made
animals fight each other it's okay you
could you could fight each other so you
get all the guys that beat lives and
stuff and then wives that beat her
Bin's put them in there that'd be the
secret I like it I like this you know
yeah they're just against ideas every
show Oh which we should just buy that
Zoo that was on for sale yeah and then
put the humans that abuse animals into
the zoo yeah that's good and they have
to act like the animals that they abuse
it's like this was a wife beater now
he's like being a blue ass baboon and
you like paint them like that and it's
like humanity like Cirque oh my god I
think we're really onto something I'm
even more excited about the Zuma guys
let's buy that server right now we've
got to get the zoo hey guys thanks for
watching that last episode if you
haven't already make sure to hit that
subscribe button because we upload
videos every single day for you guys now
to watch more videos check them out up
here
[Music]